[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de Paf
nous allons revisiter un peu cette année
2022 une année une école dans la police
d'histoire et de la guerre et puis aussi
par beaucoup d'événements politiques
notamment en France avec des lectures
présidentielle des élections
législatives et puis évidemment les
conséquences de la guerre sur nos vies
on va évoquer tous ces événements on va
à la fois tragiques et puis aussi avec
quelques douleurs d'espoir avec Marie de
Bègue bonjour vous êtes député
renaissance des Yvelines alors merci
d'être là parce que vous avez quand même
quelques mois un peu difficiles je
suppose
une session particulièrement chargée
absolument Florence mercatrice ok
bonjour Patrice
un déris le palais
bonjour Patrice vous êtes la mère de
Chevreuse et voilà je suis ravi de vous
accueillir enfin vous êtes déjà venu
avec plaisir et Mathilde domino bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes spécialiste
de communication vous êtes aussi auteur
vous avez on avait parlé ensemble de
votre dernier livre qui s'appelait le ce
que les nobelons ça nous dit que vous
avez écrit avec Philippe branche vous
avez rencontré tout un
tiré de prix Nobel de dizaine de prix
Nobel et vous leur demandez qu'est-ce
que c'est au fond les grandes questions
de la vie et alors il se trouve que là
on a deux prix Nobel français cette
année notamment celui de Niro on en
reparlera peut-être peut-être tout à
l'heure alors je disais c'est vrai que
l'année si on regarde l'année enfin
c'est vrai que le New gordien de cette
année c'est la guerre c'est le c'est la
guerre le retour de la guerre en Europe
mais on va on va commencer quand même
par une actualité plus récente et à la
fois joyeuse et un peu triste c'est bah
c'est la finale de la c'est la Coupe du
monde de football et cette finale où
l'Argentine bat la France au tir au but
finalement c'est assez intéressant parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de polémiques avant
la tenue du Mondial et puis finalement
le le sport a pris le dessus quoi non on
peut dire ça comme ça
on peut quand même être tous fiers de la
trajectoire de l'équipe de France de
foot qui fait quand même une très belle
performance et avec des conditions qui
ont pas été facile parce qu'on se
rappelle il y a eu plusieurs blessés au
début juste au début la Coupe du Monde
et voilà il y a un peu de malédiction en
plus de celui qui remporte la Coupe du
Monde 4 ans plus tôt est-ce qu'il est
capable d'aller aussi loin donc je pense
qu'on a une grande fierté et je voudrais
dire que en plus elle est partagée par
les autres équipes de sport collectif
notamment autour du ballon on sait en
handball on est bon on est bon on a le
sport collectif
après moi je crois qu'on peut tous
interroger sur effectivement comment
sont attribués les lieux qui accueillent
ces grands événements sportifs et est-ce
que les critères ne doivent pas évoluer
en même temps que les aspirations
sociale et sociétale et ça c'est une
question légitime mais je pense que
c'est à la FIFA peut-être de
s'interroger et de repenser finalement
ce qui lui semble important comme comme
critère est-ce que c'est censé rationnel
effectivement d'avoir des stades qui
sont à moitié climatisés dans des pays
écologique
en tout cas malgré la très belle
performance de notre équipe absolument
c'est vrai que la prochaine se dire
voilà dans trois pays ce qui fait ce qui
change un petit peu peut-être les les
choses là dessus
en carbone beaucoup de trajet mais je
pense qu'on peut dire qu'une fois encore
le sport a gagné et ça c'est vraiment
chouette parce que dans notre pays le
sport c'est quand même quelque chose qui
fait d'air par-dessus tout on était un
peu sur la rétrospective de 2022 il y a
quand même eu les Jeux Olympiques aussi
en 2022 on a l'impression que c'était il
y a 10 ans parce que parce qu'il s'est
passé énormément de choses depuis mais
il y a eu les Jeux olympiques d'hiver ou
ou de manière très chauvine les Français
ont quand même plutôt été bons mais qui
ont vraiment qui ont été une belle
réussite aussi je me souviens comme ça
rapidement que
assez divers et c'est vraiment cette
valeur essentielle que je retrouve dans
le sport qui est voilà qui nous tire
tous vers l'avant et qui nous donne qui
nous redonne la pêche et le sourire pour
pour une cause finalement qui est
partagée et qui fait pas débat voilà et
l'équitation se déroulera dans les
Yvelines pour les jeunes qui fait partie
des trois sports qu'on aura la chance
d'accueillir dans les Yvelines oui dans
un cadre magnifique qui est le château
de Versailles alors qui fait un petit
peu débat parce que le cadre est
somptueux et puis en même temps les le
monde cavalier grince un petit peu des
dents parce qu'il reste il en restera
pas grand chose on se dit souvent qu'on
veut garder un héritage de ces jeux or
les installations on se doute bien
qu'elle en ne resteront pas dans
l'accord du château de Versailles je
pense que ça fait partie
on pourra renvoyer une image au monde
quand même de notre histoire de notre
tradition et je pense que ça c'est ce
qu'il faut aussi garder c'est cette
image qu'on va renvoyer sur le monde
je suis devenue petit à petit en tout
cas c'était des moments émotions
populaires qui ont été partagées et ça
fait du bien dans ce contexte d'avoir
cette ferveur il y a eu le Maroc aussi
qui a été une très très bonne surprise
donc ça c'est important aussi avec c'est
vrai que avec des manifestations de joie
à Paris notamment qui ont pas qui ont
pas débouchés sur des violences comme
parfois ça peut avoir lieu quoi oui et
donc d'avoir ces temps de communion
finalement on va partager et ce qui est
intéressant c'est la place de la
télévision on l'a vu pas mal cette année
avec l'enterrement d'Elisabeth 2 aussi
ou la télévision finalement reprend le
dessus on vit en direct ce qui se passe
il y a l'adrénaline on a pu le voir
encore dimanche dernier l'adrénaline des
derniers penalties donc ça c'est
important aussi comme
vous disiez c'est à dire que il y a 25
millions de de téléspectateurs pour la
finale c'est-à-dire que c'est vraiment
énorme ça c'est le record historique je
crois donc d'audience à la télé oui et
donc là c'est la force du direct
on n'en doute pas une seconde
je peux témoigner c'est qu'hier soir
j'étais au Théâtre du Rond-Point sur les
Champs-Élysées et
pas loin de la Concorde c'est vrai que
c'était compliqué
donc c'était pas compliqué mais en
revanche quand nous sommes sortis on a
croisé les supporters qui remontaient de
la Concorde et je pense que là c'était
un symbole de tout ce que porte le sport
c'était très familial il y avait des
enfants des parents les grands-parents
et avec des gens qui étaient franchement
très enfin ils avaient l'air heureux les
drapeaux français et je pense que ça ça
résume bien
cette coupe du monde que vous les
Français et effectivement nous ont fait
rêver presque jusqu'au bout
alors vous êtes un peu sceptique sur le
sur le plan
j'allais dire sur le plan politique
c'est pas le plan politique mais sur la
présence du président de la République
c'était normal voilà normal qu'il soit
là ce qui m'a un peu gêné parce que je
trouvais que c'était probablement un peu
de récupération de communication
politique c'était une présence trop
forte sur le terrain une fois que la
finale était terminée où il a fallu
qu'il prenne Mbappe quatre fois dans ses
bras pour le consoler je puis ensuite
qu'il aille qu'il aille supporter
l'équipe de France il y a aucun débat
là-dessus mais là j'ai trouvé qu'il en
faisait peut-être un tout petit peu trop
en tant que président de la République
il peut pas être juste là comme étant
insupportun mais voilà donc j'ai trouvé
voilà je l'ai trouvé voilà je l'ai
trouvé
dépassant
je dis pas qu'il fallait pas qu'il soit
là il fallait qu'il soit là mais je l'ai
trouvé
au-delà de son rôle de président de la
République il peut pas se présenter
comme ça me supporter de l'équipe de
France il peut supporter l'équipe de
France puis je trouve qu'il est allé un
peu loin dans sa présence voilà en plus
je pense que Mbappé avait peut-être
plutôt besoin qu'on lui fiche la paix et
que de se retrouver 4 fois qu'est-ce
qu'on se retrouve 4 fois dans les bras
d'Emmanuel Macron j'ai trouvé que
c'était un peu trop et du coup frison un
peu la communication
politiquement
je suis un petit peu d'accord avec vous
et en même temps je pense que Emmanuel
Macron fait pas un mystère sur sa
passion pour les football et que je me
dis voilà et et c'est pas fin je pense
alors vous trouverez
je suis pas avare de critique à
l'endroit du Président de la République
mais là je trouve que c'était pas fin
c'était assez naturel après c'est des
images qu'on a bien voulu en renvoyer
là vous voyez sur l'écran qui est
derrière Patrice effectivement sur 4
images peu près deux fois le président
de la République parce que c'est l'image
qu'on veut en renvoyer mais je pense que
c'était pas fin c'était assez natural
c'est peut-être pas sa place à sa fin
dans les deux sens c'était pas oui
déjà inversement juste moi j'avoue que
j'ai été étonné surtout de pas voir le
président argentin parce que j'avais
trouvé très sympathique le moment de
partage finalement entre la présidente
de la République de Croatie et Emmanuel
Macron il y a 4 ans non mais c'est vrai
que bon en plus on gagnait donc c'était
c'était peut-être plus inconfortable
pour elle que pour nous mais j'avais
trouvé justement que bon après c'était
aussi un autre pays européen mais
j'avais trouvé que ça crée aussi une
relation un peu particulière avec ce
pays et donc voilà j'étais enfin à vrai
dire j'ai regardé qui c'était où dans le
dans le panel des hommes présents voilà
mais j'ai vu qu'il est j'ai lu qu'il
voulait pas y aller qu'il trouvait voilà
donc non non mais c'est vrai que ça
parait assez cohérent après honnêtement
j'ai entendu les les
de certains sur la place du Président je
suis d'accord c'est aussi ce qu'on veut
bien en montrer mais moi je sais pas
dire qu'elle est aussi son degré de
proximité avec Kylian Mbappe
je sais pas
je crois qu'ils échangent mais je ne
sais pas quel est le degré de proximité
et je pense que ça joue aussi peut-être
de savoir si on a beaucoup de contact
avec lui ou si on en a peu j'imagine que
que ça et puis bon c'est insupportun de
foot de toutes ces vidances c'est
insupportable premier plan au vu de ça
ça place donc voilà je je j'entends de
façon quoi qu'il aurait fait il aurait
eu des choses auraient été dites dans
tous les cas c'est super bien il est
supporter de l'équipe de France pas de
Mbappé quoi c'était avec tous les il
aurait pu aller voir aussi enfin voilà
on a Jacques Chirac en toile de fond
aussi donc le président qui est endos le
maillot et qui va sur le terrain aussi
une grille de lecture politique
finalement c'est Macron qui va sur le
terrain c'est Macron qui va être évalué
tous les mots qui va exprimer voilà
toute cette parole va être entendue
aussi comme le chef de l'État voilà avec
une lecture politique on voit aussi que
c'est le supporter qui prend la parole
comme il a été supporté de l'OM et donc
dans ce moment-là on voit qu'il y a un
enthousiasme il y a une frénésie aussi
qui est partagée par l'ensemble des
Français et dont Emmanuel Macron après
c'est vrai qu'on critique on dit à la
récupération politique moi je suis pas
enfin je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait une
grande un grand intérêt à cette
récupération politique on se rappelle
quand même qu'en 2018 il y a la victoire
de de l'équipe de France au Mondial et
puis il y a le mouvement des gilets
jaunes qui arrivent peu de temps après
donc je suis pas sûr que politiquement
évidemment il y a peut-être autre chose
c'est peut-être le moral des Français
qui est qui est revigoré par un bon
comportement de l'équipe de France une
victoire
plus qu'en 2010 ou nice night avait eu
ce joueur qui voulait pas descendre du
bus évidemment là on était tous
pessimiste
je pense qu'on a tous enfin on a tous
non voilà peut-être en tout cas ma
génération on a observé que la Coupe du
Monde de 98 avait pas du tout provoqué
le même effet que la Coupe du Monde de
2018 98 on est resté dans cet effet
Coupe du Monde tous l'été face à
vraiment
en 98 et puis il y a eu cette descente
des Champs-Élysées et puis il y a eu
voilà
tout à fait tout à fait certainement
2018 on est resté
je pense que ce qu'on vécu 98 donc je
fais partie et qui s'en souviennent on
est resté un peu sur notre coin sur de
2018 on est resté un peu sur notre fin
un peu le bus qui est descendu un peu
la joie n'était peut-être c'était la
joie de la première fois enfin j'ai pas
d'explication précise et on en a fait en
effet une lecture politique avec cette
France blackber etc donc il y avait
qui s'est soldé par l'arrivée de l'Open
au deuxième tour en 2002 enfin tout à
fait mais donc il était peut-être pas
aussi aussi vrai qu'on le respirait mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a une lecture plus
politique me semble-t-il en 98 peut-être
aussi à cause de la cohabitation et
Chirac j'ose pas qu'il est se présenter
au présidentiel
2018 ça a été beaucoup moins politique
moi je trouve que c'est aussi un peu le
mythe du temps passé de de voilà on
idéalise un peu toujours moi j'ai connu
du coup 98 mais j'avais 8 ans
2018 et là moi je trouve on a toujours
une bonne belle fierté à voir son équipe
qui progresse qui passe les étapes je
rappelle le match sur l’angleterre mais
quelle pression on a eu quoi on s'est
dit à la la pourvu que ce soit pas tout
de suite là et pour vous ce serait pas
tout de suite la fin de l'aventure parce
qu'au final on partage ce moment
collectif et je sais pas si
effectivement aussi peut-être
l'enchaînement de l'actualité les
chaînes d'infos on continue enfin la
rapidité aussi de l'information chaise
beaucoup plus les les les événements en
revanche je trouve que peut-être le
sentiment de joie s'évapore un peu plus
vite mais moi je me rappelle de Nice na
en 2010 et quel malaise franchement
beaucoup plus sac
contre les joueurs mais parce que on en
parle encore aujourd'hui avec ce côté un
peu de rouge de la France qui est un peu
écornée effectivement je sais pas ce
qu'il restera de ces deux Coupes du
monde
2018-202 après dans dans l'esprit
collectif puis c'est aussi les valeurs
que vont incarner les joueurs au fil du
temps je veux dire là la fierté elle
vient aussi de c'est une équipe qui est
assez composée enfin de joueurs assez
jeune
qui sont quand même beaucoup aussi
et qui sont aussi attentifs je pense
porter un certain nombre de valeurs
incarner un certain nombre de valeurs
plutôt que les porter et qui nous
rendent assez fier je trouve beaucoup
plus que ce qu'on a pu vivre en 2010
en 98 vous avez tous remarqué que la
société de cartes qui transporte les
bleus et yvelinoise elle est même
chevrotines donc je j'en ai d'autant
plus de fierté bon on va pas du tout les
citer c'est la SAVAC et qui transforme
Miss France également on a ils ont quand
même des beaux contrats
en 98 le bus le bus qui a descendu les
Champs-Élysées qui était floqué
magnifiquement a servi à faire du
transport scolaire pendant les six ou
huit mois qui ont suivi vous imaginez
les étoiles dans les yeux des gamins
quand ils se retrouvaient dans le bus
des Bleus floqué champion du monde etc
en 2018 le but est revenu on a eu trois
heures pour s'amuser à faire des photos
avec le château de Chevreuse en fond
d'écran il des développer tout de suite
parce que les sponsors parce que les
contrats parce que les filles parce que
là
changement
de ces de ces gamins qui prenaient le
bus dans le bus des champions du monde
en 98 pour laquelle c'était mais le rêve
absolue c'est pas grand chose c'est
vraiment tout simple c'est pas
grand-chose et c'est déception en 2018
de il fallait tout enlever il fallait
que le bus soit déshabiller le plus
rapidement possible voilà c'est un tout
petit point de détail par exemple cette
anecdote ridicule mais de l'époque aussi
ça a dit plein de choses de l'époque et
je pense que ça aussi enlève une part du
rêve qui a autour de autour de tout ça
figure de MVP on l'a vu encore pendant
le match de dimanche elle est cruciale
aussi finalement ce sont sa ténacité ça
ça résistance aussi de ne rien lâcher à
l'âge qu'il a c'est très très important
aussi et c'est un signal qui est renvoyé
donc ça c'est ça c'est passionnant oui
il y a beaucoup d'espoir aussi parce que
en effet ils sont plutôt jeunes enfin il
va y avoir quelques-uns qui vont partir
enfin il y a une relève qui qu'on voit
là qui commence à prendre
absolument alors pour aller dans le dans
le sens de votre anecdote alors là c'est
peut-être pas une anecdote mais en 98 en
disait Black Blanc beurre je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus le dire
c'est dire c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on peut plus dire black on dit personne
de couleur
ok on va peut-être passer des vêtements
peut-être plus tragique mais qui a qui
au fond l'événement qui marque toute
cette année qui a des conséquences
politiques et économiques évidemment
essentielle c'est la guerre
[Musique]
alors c'est le 24 février que que
Poutine annonce l'invasion de l'Ukraine
il n'y a pas de déclaration officielle
de guerre est-ce que vous vous souvenez
de de ce moment-là
du côté de mon mari ma belle-sœur est
d'origine ukrainienne elle est arrivée
en France quand elle avait à peu près 20
ans et depuis elle est mariée avec mon
beau-frère et elle vit en faisant
forcément
on se sent très impliqué et très et très
impacté et puis je crois que c'est aussi
une forme de sidération face à quelque
chose qu'on imaginait parce que voir en
fait moi comme ça mais que on y croyait
pas en France notamment on est d'une on
y croyait pas et surtout la
guerre a tellement évolué dans ses
formes je veux dire pardon c'est pas
totalement mais sous forme de conflit de
tranchées un peu où on essaye de
conquérir du territoire ou la logistique
joue un rôle majeur ou finalement c'est
c'est de l'infanterie si vous regardez
aujourd'hui la façon dont on perd les
forces françaises
on en voit souvent des commandos des
leads pour faire des frappes ponctuelles
etc alors que là on est vraiment sur on
envoie tout toute une classe d'âge ce
battre et donc ouais un effet de
sidération très très fort
quand à ce qui se passe et puis là en
quelque sorte l'enneigement du conflit
ça fait ça fait près d'un an et demi
et puis qu'est-ce que ça va donner
est-ce qu'on arrivera à un moment à
stabiliser les frontières et à arrêter
vous voyez même les espèces de de de
guerre permanente entre ces deux pays
même si c'est dans des beaucoup plus
petits espaces géographiques je trouve
que ça interroge beaucoup c'est une
évidence mais c'est vrai que je me
souviens les services secrets américains
disaient tous oui il va y avoir une
invasion de l'Ukraine par la poutine par
la Russie et il y avait et je sais pas
moi
on se disait la guerre c'est pas
possible quoi j'ai l'impression avait ce
sentiment là j'ai repris une carte
parce qu'on nous parlait depuis
6-7 ans 8 ans de la Crimée c'était
devenu un petit peu le bruit de fond on
s'y intéressait enfin franchement qui
qui a fait de grosses analyses poussées
et enfin c'était vraiment un conflit à
bas bruit
voilà les quelques souvenirs de cours
d'histoire de géopolitique il y a le
temps etc enfin bon et
ce 24 février je me souviens très bien
que mon réflexe a été de reprendre une
carte on nous a parlé de l'invasion du
don-basse pardon et moi avant le 24
février je savais pas où était le nom de
base
aujourd'hui ça part évident Mario Paul
je j'avais une vision assez imprécise
d'où était Mario Paul donc
voilà avec le football
moi j'ai d'abord repris une carte et
puis et puis rappelez-vous cette ces 15
premiers jours on nous est dit ça va
être plié
que penser à peu près tout le monde mais
même les Ukrainiens d'ailleurs même de
je pense qu'ils se voyaient mal engagé
et puis
moi ça m'a pardon de cette anecdote très
personnelle mais j'avais attaché peu
d'importance à ce qui se passait en
Crimée et du coup j'ai j'en ai profité
pour voilà visiter revisiter cette
histoire
pratiquement depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale c'est quand
même pas vraiment compliqué cette partie
du monde et c'est vraiment une charnière
c'est aussi qui fait que voilà
c'était c'était l'URSS réalité voilà il
y avait il y a des pays qui est des
nationalités très très différentes enfin
entre dans ce qui était sous cette chape
de plomb et puis on était aussi habitués
je dirais dans cette fin de 20e siècle
début du 21e à des conflits plutôt sur
fond religieux que sur fond politique et
donc je pense qu'il y a aussi cette
surprise
tout à fait et cette invasion pour de la
conquête territoriale finalement ça nous
paraissait plus d'actualité enfin plier
fini dans tous fait des discours du 8
mai du 11 novembre où on a
encensé les vertus de la paix et de
l'Europe qui nous a permis de garder
vraiment
pour nous c'était acquis la construction
européenne avait été faite pour ça et ça
marchait c'est bien il y a plus de
guerre en Europe quoi et peut-être clin
d'oeil un peu maléfique de l'histoire
c'est que les accords de Yalta Yalta
c'est en Crimée et les accords de Yalta
qui ont été une des étapes peut-être la
plus médiatique au sens de l'époque de
la sortie de la deuxième guerre mondiale
ont pris corps on précore en Crimée je
pense que les sept notre état un peu de
sidération c'est que on s'attendait pas
une guerre en Europe donc les guerres
c'est
loin de chez nous c'est en Afrique c'est
loin de la guerre en Europe c'est ça qui
fait que la tragédie de l'histoire si on
peut dire voilà exactement
c'est vrai que on n'était pas du tout
préparé puisque comme vous le disiez
Patrice en France on en parlait pas on
aura on en parlait pas il y avait les
Américains
on avait des anciens pays qui étaient
sous la domination de l'URSS et la
menace voilà avec Poutine pour pouvoir
de leur situation géographique aussi
différentes hein c'est vrai que ça soit
la Pologne enfin assez différent de de
celle qu'on peut avoir en France enfin
par rapport au conflits ils sont en
avant
effectivement la population chez nous
comme vous l'avez très bien dit je suis
pas sûr que tout le monde savait très
très bien où était l'Ukraine je ne suis
pas sûr que les gens réalisent aussi la
non non pardon mais plus largement je
et une frontière commune et que donc en
fait euh comme vous êtes en Ukraine vous
êtes quasiment en Europe déjà je suis
pas sûr que tout le monde réalise bien
le jeu malsain qu'organise Poutine dans
cette région le le côté aussi l'alliance
avec la Biélorussie qui met une pression
supplémentaire à l'Ukraine hein parce
que tout le monde regarde ça que tout le
monde réalise que c'est on est à portée
de missile en réalité donc des deux
côtés et on a eu je me rappelle de cette
séquence au Parlement là pendant la
session quand deux missiles sont tombés
en en Pologne et où finalement on en
parle plus voilà on sait pas très bien
qui les a tiré comment ils sont arrivés
là etc mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
nous au Parlement je m'en rappelle tout
le monde a dit mais attendez c'est la
Pologne qui est touché est-ce que ça
veut dire que la France risque de
rentrer en guerre prochainement et
encore une fois aussi c'est très
différent parce que on a certes cette
journée d'appel à la préparation
militaire on a de plus de Français qui
s'engagent dans une forme de réserve
reser citoyenne réserves militaires etc
mais on a une armée de métiers une armée
qui est professionnalisée et que si la
France rentre en guerre ce serait très
très différent de ce qu'on a pu
connaître aujourd'hui avec en plus une
armée qui a une capacité à se projeter
un peu partout dans dans le monde malgré
les faiblesses parfois logistiques qu'on
peut qu'on peut connaître il faut être
honnête mais je pense que la population
n'a effectivement on a tous connu une
forme de choc je suis pas sûr que nos
dirigeants nos états majors militaires
ne se soit pas rendu compte de la menace
et d'ailleurs le dialogue
qui a toujours persévéré entre le
Président de la République et Vladimir
Poutine et volodimeinski et peut-être
les critiques qu'on peut on pourrait
formuler à ce titre mais montre aussi
que
du point de vue de nos responsables
politiques et je parle pas
Renaissance ou n'importe quel autre ce
qui était dans dans la logique de
décision était quand même informé de de
la menace parce que bien sûr je suis ces
points avec une attention une vigilance
particulière il a informé et préparé
ce reportage assez ce qui était pas
vraiment au reportage mais plutôt un
documentaire assez intéressant sur les
quelques jours qui précède l'invasion et
qui montre l'intensité peut-être
peut-être on n'imaginait pas que ça
allait se déclencher si vite mais qui
montre l'intensité des contacts entre
pour le 3 pays et puis internationaux
plus globalement et qui démontre bien
que
la menace était prise au sérieux et
alors il y a évidemment un personnage
qui est apparu une fois qu'on a
découvert avec ce conflit c'est le
président de l'Ukraine vous le dire
Zelinski
qui était considéré un moment enfin
c'est il avait assez mauvaise image
avant la gaffe audio c'est un clown qui
est devenu président quoi en gros
c'était ça et puis on découvre de vous
quelqu'un qui se veut dire qui qui c'est
pas une conduite absolument incroyable
exceptionnel non
c'est une bataille de Limoges aussi par
rapport à petit évidemment et l'enjeu
c'est aussi la l'opinion publique
internationale pour convaincre les
dirigeants les décideurs c'est c'est
crucial ziananski on l'a vu prendre la
parole se servir de l'ensemble des
canaux de communication sur le terrain
absolument allez rencontrer aussi les
décideurs aller dans les institutions
des autres pays mobiliser et donc ça
c'est évidemment crucial puisque ça se
joue aussi et surtout on le voit sur ce
plan là
et c'est vrai que c'est vrai que il y a
un côté effectivement
je reste avec sa femme je crois qu'il
est là-bas je sais pas s'ils ont des
enfants mais qui je crois aussi à Kiev
je reste sur le terrain je mène
personnellement
la bataille de l'image et
particulièrement face à mais même si
malgré tout je suis pas sûr que alors
que ce sont deux pays qui ont des liens
de
l'éternité extrême fort que ça ait un
impact sur le peuple russe parle pas de
sur les dirigeants russes parce que là
je pense que c'est plié mais je sais pas
qu'est-ce qui perçoivent aussi et
qu'est-ce que les inciter à un moment se
poser parce que tout le monde dit que le
sentiment patriotique voire nationaliste
a été quand même très largement entre
tenu en Russie de ce que j'en comprends
et de ce que j'en lis et je sais pas si
mais bon à minima effectivement ça sert
pour les autres pays du monde et oui
mais c'est primordial et je pense que
c'est là ça a été l'adresse de du
président ukrainien c'est de se dire que
on imagine je connais pas bien la Russie
mais on imagine que les canaux de
communication sont quand même assez
filtrés assez bouchées mais le président
ukrainien a eu un besoin
incommensurable de soutien des autres
pays donc je pense que dans au moins sur
toute une partie de de l'orientation de
sa communication elle était plus
orientée vers l'Europe et les États-Unis
que vers ses propres pays où je pense
que quand on est bombardé on est d'abord
préoccupé sur comment on va manger se
chauffer se déplacer
survivre
on sait qu'en Russie c'est bloqué et je
pense qu'on a entre le président enfin
entre Poutine et Zelinski on a vraiment
la guerre à la mode du 20e face à la
guerre à la mode du 21e avec on l'a vu
Poutine alors vu de l'extérieur comme
vous le disiez tout à fait on a quand
même assez peu de d'image de la manière
dont cette communication est ressentie à
l'intérieur des deux pays
de l'extérieur mais le rôle des pays
extérieurs étant surtout pour l'Ukraine
étant primordial je pense qu'il a eu
cette adresse de s'appuyer sur une
communication moderne et efficace et qui
a du mobiliser un peu parfois
ne serait-ce qu'en France rappelez-vous
février mars la classe politique était
quand même pas unanime
très diverses mais il y avait pas
l'unanimité or maintenant on entend plus
enfin beaucoup moins je pense que la
question se pose
le discours ils avaient c'était pas là
durcissement
peut-être que ça a eu d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure mais peut-être des conséquences
aussi sur la sur la présidentielle je
reviens ce que vous disiez sur les
piscines de en Pologne évidemment alors
il y a les pays qui appartiennent dans
le temps le crâne n'appartient pas au
loto donc il y a pas cette cette
réciprocité d'attaque ou on est obligé
d'attaquer celui qui a attaque un pays
de l'OTAN c'est vrai qu'il y a derrière
tout ça il y a quand même et ça aussi ça
fait partie de la tragédie de de cette
guerre il y a
le risque nucléaire quand même qui qui
est derrière tout ça et parce que
Poutine m'a toujours dit que voilà
servir un jour ou l'autre donc ça aussi
ça ça nous
enfin
et malgré tout même si ce n'était pas
une aromatomie que
l'explosion dans cette centrale à
Tchernobyl qui est en Ukraine
démontre aussi et ça n'a rien à voir
avec une attaque nucléaire on est
d'accord mais ça démontre aussi déjà ne
serait-ce que lorsque vous avez un nuage
nucléaire qui passe au-dessus de
l'Europe ce que ça peut générer en
termes de conséquences sur la santé en
termes de conséquences sur les
inquiétude légitime de de nos
populations et encore plus quand vous
êtes quand vous êtes en état frontalier
donc de toute évidence c'est une menace
qui est très prise au sérieux et c'est
pour ça que moi je veux vraiment salut
l'engagement pour enfin je parle du
point de vue de la France parce que je
ne sais pas
quels sont les outils d'engagement qui
ont pu être pris par des chefs d'État
étrangers mais de ne jamais perdre le
contact avec le président Poutine quand
bien même Macron dans ton contact
c'est des choses donc en tout cas je
suis pas sûr que isolé ou mépriser un
pays ce soit le meilleur moyen de
s'assurer enfin de d'une forme
d'apaisement ou de modération si on peut
les qualifier ainsi dans un conflit donc
je pense que
je pense que ce dialogue il est
absolument fondamental et que en tout
cas il est bien mené par les dirigeants
européens au sens large et notamment par
le Président de la République
il était président de l'Europe Emmanuel
Macron au début là jusqu'à jusqu'à juin
et je trouve qu'il a il a effectivement
eu un rôle extrêmement important
qui continue à le critiquer juste
l'histoire nous montre que toutes les
guerres se finissent autour d'une table
donc il va bien falloir
et puis et puis ne pas parler ne pas
parler à la Russie pardon de faire un
petit retour en arrière c'est ce serait
comme ne pas parler au Qatar on parlait
on a commencé sur le foot bah écoutez
tous les pays sont pas tous aussi
fréquentables que
enfin qu'on pourrait voilà ou que nos
proches voisins on va dire dans notre
modèle à nous d'ailleurs puisque en
fonction des yeux par ils sont vus
peut-être qu'on est un pays
infréquentable pour certains autres pays
du monde pour autant les équilibres
politiques et la diplomatie font que il
y a des pays sur les cas avec lesquels
on est obligé d'échanger obligé de
parler et obliger de d'essayer de
d'avoir des des points de convergence
vous êtes de défendredettes
ce qui vont pouvoir négocier parce que
c'est pas l'heure de toute façon
sur l'Europe quand même elle est-ce
qu'elle ressort grandi de ce conflit en
tout cas
elle parle d'une voix en dehors des
questions énergétiques parce que les
enjeux sont extrêmement partagés mais
sur le soutien à l'Ukraine sur la
logique agresseur agressée je crois
qu'elle parle du doigt unanime et puis
peut-être juste par exemple de
l'Allemagne par rapport
l'armée européenne par la défense
européenne je trouve en tout cas
l'Europe est
elle revient dans les moments de très
forte tension on l'a connu aussi pendant
le covid assez valeurs fondamentales qui
sont la coopération le travail ensemble
même si on même si on s'échappe le reste
du temps même s'il y a des points de vue
qui sont extrêmement différents même si
on n'aborde pas les questions de la même
manière quand l'Europe sous pression et
même c'est difficile quand l'Europe est
mise sous elle est capable de revenir à
ses valeurs essentielles et ce qui fait
ce pourquoi on sait allez moi je
voudrais juste dire un mot aussi c'est
que inversement il faut regarder aussi
les votes à l'ONU sur la scène
internationale quand il s'agit de
sanctionner la Russie etc il y a
beaucoup de pays qui s'appellent et donc
il faut pas nier le poids du soft power
aussi russe et moi je le vois pour avoir
présidé le groupe d'études de le groupe
d'amitié France Côte d'Ivoire avec la
Côte d'Ivoire enfin dans cette
ère où la France est extrêmement
influente du du Mali du Burkina de la
Côte d'Ivoire du Sénégal etc la montée
en puissance de rue et donc il ne faut
pas le nier et d'une il faut être très
ferme sur les valeurs auxquelles nous
croyons mais de deux je pense que isoler
la Russie refuser d'échanger avec eux
etc c'est aussi pousser tout un tas de
pays qui cherchent finalement une autre
forme de régime que le régime
démocratique auquel on croit et qui se
tourne vers la Russie comme comme un
allié objectif et donc ça c'est à mon
avis pour moi à long terme aussi une
menace qui est assez forte et qu'on ne
peut pas exclure il y a un documentaire
assez formidable sur la fabrique du sur
Wagner et qui explique exactement ce que
vous êtes en train de dire
et ça il grignote il grignote très
sérieusement un certain nombre de pays
et c'est très inquiétant je pense que
pour l'Europe c'est un vrai crash test
même si ça a été pensé comme ça et à mon
avis
Poutine n'avait pas prévu que ça se
passe comme ça non plus parce qu'on
avait toutes les raisons ne pas être
d'accord
dès que l'énergie était touchée on sait
que la politique énergétique est malgré
tout au centre de nos économies et avec
des points de vue comme vous l'avez
rappelé très très divergent en fonction
des pays et en fonction des directions
qui ont été prises bien longtemps avant
donc c'était un vrai crash test avec
une probabilité assez forte que le
système explose en vol or il a tenu et
comme vous le disiez
en tenant il s'est révélé beaucoup plus
fort et je pense que l'Europe
aujourd'hui l'Europe qui était peut-être
un concept très économique et très il y
a encore quelques mois enfin avant ces
événements en Ukraine a pris une
identité humaine une identité
géopolitique importantes depuis un an
il faut que ça
représente que l'otanique
pour la raison peut-être qu'on disait
aussi que une attaque d'un pays de
l'OTAN oblige à une riposte tu vois donc
peut-être qu'on va passer pardon
on a découvert aussi combien le peuple
craignant et résistant a fait preuve de
ténacité aussi ça ça a été une manière
justement de s'en rendre compte dès le
début du conflit et pour revenir à ce
que vous disiez d'éviter d'isoler
justement la Russie il y a un vrai enjeu
c'est de maintenir le dialogue tout en
évitant d'humilier la Russie pour la
suite en effet avec tous ces sujets
d'influence pour les jeunes générations
avec l'importance des médias avec tout
l'importance des canaux de communication
aussi qui vont être des vraies leviers
qui vont imposer des biais des grilles
de lecture pour la suite pour les pour
les autres générations
philosophique c'est vrai qu'on avait
l'impression que
mourir pour sa patrie ses idées ses
valeurs c'était quelque chose de dépassé
on voit que peut-être dans cas d'attaque
comme ça c'est quelque chose qui reste
encore quoi
une abnégation
c'est admirable alors on va peut-être
passer parce que malheureusement elles
vont très vite
aux conséquences du conflit alors
conséquence multiple politique
économique on en parle tout de suite
[Musique]
alors on va peut-être passer très vite
sur la présidentielle on a dit un mot
c'est vrai que le conflit le conflit est
arrivé en pleine d'élection
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron n'avait
pas encore déclaré sa candidature
du président de l'Europe que vous le
disiez et c'est vrai que c'était
compliqué de se déclarer sa candidature
au moment où le conflit est éclaté
c'est vrai qu'on a vu des changements
notamment Éric Zemmour qui était qui
était qui était en haut dans les
sondages il est probable que sa
proximité avec Poutine lui
cela dit bizarrement c'est Marine Le Pen
qui en a profité alors qu'elle était pas
très éloignée non plus de
Poutine enfin
elle était financée par la Russie donc
tout ça tout ça est un peu compliqué
mais c'est vrai que ça a joué autrement
le conflit sur la sur l'élection et ça a
donné et c'était compliqué pour les
autres candidats d'ailleurs de se mettre
au niveau de celui qui présidait qui
était Emmanuel Macron de toute façon
c'était des circonstances
exceptionnelles mais je vais vous dire
il y avait déjà pour le président de
réussir à se positionner effectivement
en leader européen puisqu'il était à ce
moment-là à la tête de l'Union
européenne de ne pas faire de fautes je
veux dire le piège était aussi énorme
hein pour nous et enfin pour le
président de la République et donc pour
sa majorité et inversement j'ai trouvé
que ça va être une campagne
particulièrement compliquée parce que on
sentait bien même vous voyez dans les
Yvelines on a à la fin 10 députés
Renaissance sur les les douze et ce qui
montre bien qu'on est plutôt dans un
territoire qui est assez favorable au
président de la République même dans ces
territoires là qui sont en plus
relativement préservés d'un point de vue
économique il y a des il y a des
endroits où c'est plus difficile mais il
y a il y a des il y a des départements
où la situation est beaucoup plus
compliquée etc même là on sentait une
immense inquiétude et moi je me rappelle
on faisait campagne on parlait deux
trois minutes de la présidentielle parce
que bah c'était quand même notre
actualité et très rapidement on
rebasculait vers la guerre en Ukraine
vers les conséquences vers ce que ça
allait avoir comme impact et on parlait
même pas des enjeux énergétiques à ce
moment-là on parlait juste de potentiel
entrer en conflit de notre pays de du
risque d'entraînement de du risque aussi
d'avoir une Russie qui va très très vite
et qui arrive tout de suite à l'ouest de
l'Ukraine et aux portes de au bord de
l'Europe et ça a été une campagne
à la fois très apathique et en même
temps difficile parce qu'on sentait bien
que les gens étaient préoccupés par
autre chose absolument et ça c'était à
prendre en compte aussi dans les
paramètres et
ça nous a servi ça nous a des services
de campagne
de la campagne que ce soit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ou Éric Zemmour ça c'est c'est
une évidence moi je crois que
la réussite de Marine Le Pen elle est
liée plutôt à autre chose elle est liée
à une nouvelle façon de faire campagne
ou c'est très bien de réunir 3000
personnes 30 000 personnes autres cadero
mais en réalité vous faites campagnes
dans tous les petits villages quoi donc
en fait c'est je pense que c'est autre
chose mais oui ça a desservé les figues
les plus caricatural c'est une évidence
et en même temps le piège était aussi
immense pour nous parce que votre
capacité à faire le bilan à parler de
votre projet le risque d'avoir un moment
de la part de votre candidat
une phrase malheureuse ou maladroite
était aussi très important et on sentait
bien que nos concitoyens ils avaient
l'esprit
toujours est-il le résultat est là c'est
la première fois qu'un président hors
cohabitation réélu ce qui est quand même
assez exceptionnel quoi vous attribuez
ça y est ce qu'on fait peut-être la FAI
des des gens qui étaient face à lui hors
cohabitation depuis le quinquennat a
priori les cohabitations sauf accidents
mais on a plus ces deux ans
on a pu se mettre
Giscard ou Sarkozy ou Hollande qui s'est
pas représenté n'ont pas pu être élu
enfin tout à fait j'avais une analyse
pardon qui m'est assez personnel après
la première élection de du président de
la République qui tendait à dire que le
centre puisque pardon de mettre le
président de la République au centre le
genre de droit de dire à gauche
et l'endos il est à droite enfin bon peu
importe un centre assez large on va dire
le centre est condamné à réussir parce
que si le centre ne réussit pas
forcément les extrêmes qui montrent
et je pense que malheureusement enfin
malheureusement que c'est vraiment la
situation à laquelle on est arrivé c'est
à dire que et je vais être assez assez
neutre puisque vous connaissez mon
engagement politique qui est pas
exactement ce qui est pas forcément
éloigné mais qui est pas exactement
celui du président de la République le
président de la République a réussi à un
certain nombre de choses on a raté
d'autres et donc on est arrivé à cette
situation où les extrêmes sont devenus
assez forts et où en revanche les
parties modérées que ce soit la droite
ou la gauche sont devenus assez
rapidement inaudibles la guerre est
venue vous le rappeliez se rajouter avec
cette cette sensation un peu naturelle
de se dire on change pas de chef pendant
la bataille donc je pense qu'un certain
nombre de de d'électeurs avant d'aller
voter qui aurait pu affirmer des
sensibilités légèrement différentes ce
sont plus facilement ralliées à une
figure en place qui est pas forcément à
installer
la machine on va dire et en revanche
le le les sondages va donner le le
président sortant un très haute enfin
voilà plus de 30%, enfin c'était en
revanche les législatives qui ont suivi
ont modérément en donnant une fois
énorme aux extrêmes
que ce soit le rassemblement national ou
la nuque sur quelque chose non elle est
fi plutôt d'ailleurs puisque c'était
quand même c'est la la partie pesante de
la formation on va dire et donc il y a
eu ce rééquilibrage et avec aujourd'hui
donc avec un grand pardon c'est mon
analyse avec un un
centre assez large qui est représenté
par le Président de la République la
droite traditionnelle la gauche
traditionnelle qu'on puisse qui n'existe
plus et les contrepoids de ce centre
sont les extrêmes à droite comme à
gauche et ça nous donne la configuration
de l'Assemblée nationale ou je vous
souhaite bien du courage parce que
moi j'ai trouvé un sondage avec qui
suivait immédiatement l'élection
présidentielle
souhaitez-vous que Emmanuel Macron
dispose d'une majorité législative oui
35% non 62% juste après c'est quand même
c'est étonnant hein
je pense
justement
dans la vie politique qu'on est et vous
Patrice parce que en fait je pense quand
même que on a un petit sujet de grille
de lecture de des aspirations de nos
compatriotes et de ce pourquoi il doit
je regardais le sondage que vous aviez
mis à l'instant sur sur les écrans
Éric Zemmour c'est quand même effondré
Valérie Pécresse personne n'aurait parié
enfin même moi qui viens initialement du
centre droit je n'aurais jamais pensé
que une formation politique telle que
les républicains façon de 5%. c'est
aberrant je veux dire voilà et du Parti
socialiste
vous avez cru était déjà amorcé
n'est pas un reflet de la sensibilité
politique du pays elle est nettement
plus éclatée que ce qu'on a pu vivre par
le passé elle est peut-être mieux
retraduite à l'Assemblée nationale après
moi je veux dire deux choses il y a
d'une une assemblée qui en dehors du
budget mais je veux dire n'importe quel
élu c'est que quand vous votez le budget
c'est une forme de de blanc sain que
vous donnez à au leader que ce soit un
maire une présidente de région ou un
président de la République et que donc
quand vous voulez marquer votre
opposition qu'elle soit très importante
ou qu'elle soit finalement qu'il y ait
des points de convergence et des points
de divergence comme on peut connaître
parfois avec les républicains ou les ou
les socialistes dans la nuit
l'opposition
c'est un principe sinon ça veut dire que
vous affirmez votre soutien c'est
majorité en place
pour l'instant l'assemblée avance elle
est au travail il y a des textes qui
passent qui passent peut-être un rythme
moins soutenu que on a pu connaître qui
passe parfois moi je veux dire la
majorité donc que je trouve parfois un
peu déformé de notre ambition initiale
mais ça fait partie aussi du jeu en
revanche ce que je trouve
particulièrement inquiétant c'est pas
cette assemblée représentative c'est on
pourrait avoir très bien la même chose
avec un PS fort un centre fort et Dr
fort c'est la très très grande violence
qui a été importante
c'est l'image qui a envoyé violence
et comment vous l'avez il y a une
violence des mots qu'on a vu incarnée
par l'extrême droite avec bon
franchement honnêtement le juge de paix
c'est le compte-rendu c'est à dire les
personnes que vous voyez tout en bas de
l'assemblée qui note mais peu importe ce
qu'il a dit le retour en Afrique ou
qu'il retourne en Afrique est-ce que
c'est au pluriel est-ce que c'est c'est
un dérapage qu'on ne souhaiterait pas
entendre à l'Assemblée nationale dans le
cadre du respect des des de de chacun et
inversement la très grande violence
physique que notamment les députés de la
France insoumise il faut les il faut les
sortir de de l'Alliance nupestre parce
qu'ils sont quand même particulier
essaie d'importer dans le débat je veux
dire le nombre de
vous le voyez un peu mais vous le nombre
de suspensions la présidence d'Assemblée
du nom finalement c'est pas aussi
violent que que chacun a son ressenti et
je veux dire contrairement à certains de
mes collègues ça ne m'ont fait pas venir
au larmes mais
moi je suis très souvent nationale parce
que je suis francilienne donc j'ai fait
partie de ces tâches imposées aux
Français bien d'être très présent dans
l'hémicycle
et j'aime beaucoup les séances de nuit
et c'est vrai que dedans les séances et
particulièrement les séances de nuit
après une journée de débat parfois une
journée qui est qui a traversé des
tensions le nombre de suspensions ou
donc que vous ne voyez pas en tant que
grand public parce que les caméras
s'arrêtent que le public était évacué
des tribunes quand il y en a et le
nombre de moments de vraiment de
tentative de
pas dire d'agression mais de vous voyez
de contact physique qui est avec les
députés de de la France insoumise moi je
trouve que c'est extrêmement inquiétant
sur ce que ça dit du respect de notre
débat démocratique est-ce que ça dit de
l'état d'énervement de la parce que
fondamentalement je me demande si on
sonnait par exemple les députés de la
France insoumise s'il y aurait pas euh
pas des députés les électeurs de la
France insoumise si certains ne
donneraient pas une forme de validation
ou de blancs sains à cette attitude en
disant bah oui mais c'est soit la
révolution dans la rue soit la
révolution de la musique mais non en
fait c'est pas ça je veux dire pardon
mais j'ai vu une vidéo de d'une
assemblée c'est pas au Sénégal en
Afrique ou les députés en viennent à se
jeter les chaises pardon mais je
n'aspire pas à ça pour mon pays ni dans
la qualité des débats je suis très
opposé avec ce que dit le RN ce que dit
la France insoumise c'est pas mes
convictions politiques pour autant je
pense qu'on peut débattre de manière
respectueuse et ça veut dire ne jamais
s'engueuler ça veut dire juste
quand même une culture de la négociation
du compromis c'est vrai qu'on a pas ça
peut-être à cause du régime justement
majoritaire qui fait qu'il y avait une
majorité une opposition mais c'était
comme ça et c'est vrai que dans d'autres
pays européens il y a une culture de du
compromis au Parlement européen ça
[Musique]
ont du mal
avec quelque chose de qui est sur la
négociation on voit dans les entreprises
sur les négociations avec les syndicats
c'est du dur quand je vois moi dans mes
dossiers pour arriver à négocier pour
essayer de sortir par le haut et éviter
le conflit c'est extrêmement difficile
donc je pense que des postures figées
pour arriver à assouplir les choses avec
des gens qui sont droits dans leur
bottes pour arriver à aller faire sortir
de leur bottes pour aller vers l'autre
c'est très difficile donc je pense c'est
aussi un état d'esprit alors dans les
autres pays il y a peut-être plus
notamment dans les pays nordiques il y a
plus d'habitudes à discuter à faire de
la médiation de la médiation en France
c'est quelque chose de très compliqué à
mettre en place autant au Canada ou dans
les pays nordiques la médiation existe
mais en France je pense que la culture
en tant que telle de la négociation et
et du compromis et de la médiation et
difficile à mettre en place
un exercice de pouvoir mais il avait
peur bleue depuis 68 notamment de la
violence de voilà c'est un pays qui a
fait la révolution et qui peut faire la
révolution à tout moment et donc il faut
le manier avec précaution ça renvoie
vraiment cette image de la culture du
buzz et certains parlementaires donnent
l'impression de ne se sentir existé que
si leur petite phrase est reprise de
préférence dans le
pas forcément dans les chaînes d'infos
d'ailleurs dans les émissions de
divertissement c'est voilà c'est encore
plus drôle mais aussi beaucoup de débats
où c'est le blanc contre noir quoi aussi
cette envie d'être repris d'être
comme s'il rendait compte à leurs
électeurs vous voyez j'existe j'y étais
puisque d'ailleurs la preuve j'ai été
voilà on m'a dit à l'image
et en plus les les parlementaires qui
sont sur le fond sur le vrai la vraie
construction de leur mission
commentaires c'est à dire faire la loi
contre le gouvernement enfin l'émission
d'un député madame parlementaire en
général
n'intéresse plus personne parce que
c'est pas de ça qu'on parle en fait
c'est pas de ça qu'on parle mais
peut-être rassurer aussi du coup ce qui
nous regardent et dire je suis
totalement d'accord avec l'analyse qui a
été fait moi je trouve que le régime
présidentiel est un bon régime et je
suis pas du tout choqué par une logique
majoritaire et puis il faut pas oublier
que sous la précédente législature
certes nous avions la majorité absolue
mais il y avait quand même près il y
avait 9 entre 9 et 11 groupes en
fonction des périodes dans les musiques
mais à l'Assemblée donc il y avait aussi
une représentation qui était qui était
forte et on peut déplorer à l'époque
inversement que le rassemblement
national qui avait certes que cet élu
qui ne pouvait pas composer un groupe
qui donc avait des difficultés mais
était très très peu présent dans
l'hémicycle la réalité c'est comme ça là
il joue la surprise parce qu'ils
essayent de se notabiliser en vue de de
2027 mais la réalité
ils ont passé quand même un quinquennat
avec cette élu qui qui ne mettait pas
les pieds dans l'hémicycles c'est comme
ça mais
sur le sur le oui mais ça ne vous
empêche pas inversement je pense cet
exemple parce que je trouve qu'il est
très significatif et je ne partage pas
ses convictions mais Emmanuel Ménard
elle est seule elle est non inscrite
donc elle est dans aucun groupe ça fait
deux mandats qu'elle est inscrite et
elle est là voilà sur tous les textes
elle défend ses amendements surtout les
textes et donc c'est aussi possible et
elle est moins audible certainement mais
n'empêche qu'elle fait partie de la
construction du travail parlementaire et
effectivement vous avez raison la
réalité c'est que la construction de
fonds d'un texte de loi elle se fait pas
à travers les scandales qu'on peut voir
dans l'hémicycle et paradoxalement ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que on a
quand même une assemblée qui avance on a
voté un projet de loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat alors vous allez me dire oui
quand on dépense de l'argent tout le
monde est prêt à voter donc ça c'est un
peu vrai on a voté la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur on a voté le texte sur le la
planification des énergies renouvelables
encore une fois je mets le budget de
côté qui est vraiment
une toute autre Cabi et on a la retraite
et on arrive à la retraite on arrive au
projet de loi immigration qui va être
sur la retraite sur l'immigration et là
on verra bien s'il y a une possibilité
avec des ministres qui ont aussi compris
l'importance de réunir régulièrement les
parties d'opposition avec lesquelles on
peut travailler que le compromis se
construit doucement qu'il y a des points
de divergence très forts et que mais
mais je veux dire personne en tout cas
dans la majorité bien sûr j'ai pas
mentir peut-être que un jour sur un
texte qui est fondamental la majorité se
sortira le 49-3 dont elle a le droit
d'usage en dehors des textes budgétaires
mais mais personne n'est dans cet état
d'esprit initial tout le monde se dit
voilà c'est un recours possible mais
tout le monde est quand même dans une
logique de dire bon maintenant il faut
qu'on trouve un moyen d'avancer discuter
de faire émerger un consensus et on l'a
fait sur un certain nombre de texte et
je peux vous dire honnêtement sur les
énergies renouvelables le dé parce que
l'éolien terrestre qui est un vrai sujet
de polémique aujourd'hui en fait vous
savez pas sûr que le le panneaux
solaires se soit beaucoup mieux l'éolien
offshore quand vous êtes concernés vous
êtes souvent des populations qui sont
très opposées et pourtant le texte est
passé donc il y a quand même des choses
qui avancent
pas toujours simplement et facilement
mais en tout cas le débat il est là et
la co-construction elle est là et et les
oppositions diront toujours qu'elles
estiment ne pas être assez écouté et la
majorité dira toujours qu'elle a fait
des compromis très importants mais ce
qui est important c'est de regarder le
résultat final on avait initialement des
oppositions qui disaient oh on voudra
bien voter un amendement par-ci par là
et qui finissent par adopter des textes
donc ça avance quand même doucement et
je déplore au même titre que ce que vous
avez dit l'attitude de certains qui
consiste à se servir de de de
l'hémicycle comme
d'un lieu pour faire une ingénie
étudiante
malheureusement
peut-être pour terminer si je me fais
tuer mais vraiment une raison d'espérer
pour 2023
désespéré
c'est un peu tristoun mais quand même je
réfléchissais
pas très bien on est morose on voit nos
factures d'énergie augmentée on baisse
les radiateurs on met des cols rouler
enfin des choses qu'on n'avait pas on
n'imaginait pas vivre il y a encore
quelques années et donc j'avais cette
vision de me dire et autour de nous
comment ça va et ben finalement ça va
pas si mal que ça en France et le
français râleur mais je crois que par
moment il faut savoir reconnaître et
savoir apprécier la douceur du pays dans
lequel on vit et ok continuez à râler
parce que ça fait partie de nous mais
finalement voilà regardons autour et
réjouissons-nous les initiatives prises
dans les territoires je pense à
diversider une association qui a 5 ans
et qui justement promeut la diversité et
qui a un levier de performance dans les
organisations dans les entreprises et
donc ça c'est un bon signal pour la
jeunesse aussi
c'est une question qui est pas facile
moi je suis un naturel optimiste donc
j'ai toujours le sentiment que ça va
finir par s'arranger mais je rejoins ce
que disait madame le Maire je pense que
quand on regarde global et c'est un
sentiment peut-être un peu partagé enfin
c'est une toute petite partie de la
France mais quand je discute dans ma
circonscription les gens trouvent que
quand même
la situation en France n'est pas la pire
dans le monde et qu'il y a quand même au
global une classe politique qui répond
présente il y a quand même des voilà des
des élus locaux qui sont là des élus
nationaux qui sont présentes donc voilà
j'espère que on va finir par sortir de
ça mais je trouve quand même qu'il y a
une prise de conscience aussi de nos
compatriotes sur le fait que la
situation n'est pas si mauvaise que ça
en France merci merci beaucoup à toutes
les quatre bah ça on pourra reprendre
cette discussion parce qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de sujets peut-être qu'on se
reverra alors je ne sais pas si vous ne
dirais
merci beaucoup
[Musique]